more news out of the supreme court the  supreme court has basically denied  all of the remaining election lawsuits  so those of you who thought you could  undo the election of joe biden i'm sorry  to say  those hopes are completely dashed at  this point in a raft of one-line orders  the supreme court has basically done  away with all of these election lawsuits  this includes  kelly versus pennsylvania which was the  strongest of all of these very very weak  claims  you have king versus whitmer which was  the michigan kraken case you have  lynn woods crazy georgia case kelly  ward's crazy case in arizona  and trump's crazy case in wisconsin i've  done lots of videos on how crazy all of  these lawsuits were  but now they are done they took their  shot at the supreme court and it's over  so subscribe or i'll see you in court  unless you're trying to litigate all of  these election things in which case i  want you in court because you were  dismissed